SOMEONE WHO KNOWS THE PLAYERS
AND HAD EYES ON THE SITUATION.
MYLES TAYLOR.
THE NO-LONGER ANONYMOUS FORMER
SENIOR TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL.
YOU REMEMBER HIM TURNING WHITE
HOUSE UPSIDE DOWN IN 2018 WHEN
HE WROTE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
OP-ED AND BOOK, DECLARING HE WAS
PART OF THE RESISTANCE WORKING
TO THWART TRUMP'S WORST
INCLINATIONS AND DID,
ULTIMATELY, REVEAL HIS IDENTITY.
TAYLOR WAS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
BACK WITH US ON "PRIME TIME."
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> FIRST, THE FLAVOR.
DOES THIS SOUND AS REPORTING
REMOTELY LIKE WHAT YOU
UNDERSTAND ABOUT MILLEY, HIS
CONCERNS AND WHAT TRUMP COULD
TRIGGER IN PEOPLE LIKE HIM?
>> CHRIS, THE ANSWER IS YES,
YES, AND YES.
I WANT TO SAY TWO THINGS.
FIRST, IT'S A LLARMING.
SECOND, IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
YOU HIT ON THE POINTS.
YOU HAD THE TOP MILITARY
ADVISOR, HAND PICKED, WHO WAS SO
WORRIED ABOUT HIS MENTAL STATE
THAT HE WANTED TO BASICALLY KEEP
THE NUCLEAR CODES FROM HIM, PUTS
CHECKS AND BALANCES IN PLACE AND
TALK TO FOREIGN ADVERSARIES TO
KEEP WARS FROM BREAKING OUT.
THAT SUGGESTS THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S TOP MILITARY ADVISOR
AT THAT TIME DIDN'T SEE RUSSIA
AND CHINA AND IRAN AS THE
BIGGEST THREATS TO THE UNITED
STATES.
HE SAW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AS THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S ALARMING.
WHY IS THIS NOT SURPRISING?
BECAUSE I WITNESSED IT.
I SAW CABINET SECRETARIES IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION TALKING ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL OF INVOKING THE 25th
AMENDMENT BECAUSE THEY WERE
WORRIED THE PRESIDENT WAS SO
MENTALLY UNSTABLE.
ONE OTHER EPISODE AMONG MANY
THAT I WITNESSED THAT WAS
SIMILAR TO THE MILLEY INCIDENT.
WE HAD BEEN HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
WE ARE WORRIED THE PRESIDENT'S
RHETORIC WOULD LEAD TO A WAR
WITH NORTH KOREA.
I REMEMBER WALKING OUT OF THE
SITUATION ROOM AND THE SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE TURNED TO ME AND THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND SAID, IF YOU AREN'T
PREPARING THE HOMELAND FOR WAR,
YOU ARE NOT DOING YOUR JOBS.
HE WAS SAYING, WE JUST DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE THE SITUATION WAS
GOING TO GO BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT WAS SPIRALING.
THAT'S DEEPLY DISTURBING.
I THINK THAT REINFORCES WHAT
MILLEY SAW FIRSTHAND.
>> BACK TO HIM IN ONE SECOND.
IN TERMS OF THE THREAT, FORGET
ABOUT PUTTING MILITARY IN.
THE ASPECT OF HOW DRAMATICALLY
HE WANTED TO TAKE MILITARY OUT.
IF THE BOOK IS RIGHT ABOUT THIS
SECRET MEMO TO WITHDRAW JANUARY
15, 2021, WITH WHAT WE JUST SAW
WITH A LOT OF LEAD TIME IN
GETTING THEM OUT THAT BIDEN HAD,
WHAT DO YOU THINK MIGHT HAVE
HAPPENED IF THE MILITARY HAD
BEEN PULLED OUT THAT ABRUPTLY?
>> I HATE TO SAY IT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE WARNED
TRUMP AGAINST IN THE FIRST YEAR
W
.
WHEN HE TOOK OFFICE, HE WANTED
TO PULL OUT THAT ABRUPTLY.
HE TOLD US HE WANTED TO PULL OUT
THAT ABRUPTLY AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
HE JUST WANTED TO BE GONE FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
WE PRESSED HIM AND PRESSED HIM
AND CONVINCED HIM IN AUGUST OF
HIS FIRST YEAR TO KEEP A U.S.
TROOP PRESENCE.
BY THE END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, HE HAD GOTTEN
RID OF THE GUARDRAILS, JOHN
KELLY WHO CONVINCED HIM TO STAY
AND STAY THE COURSE.
HE HAD GOTTEN RID OF JIM MATTIS
AND
HE WANTED TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
THAT.
THE HUMANITARIAN CATASTROPHE WE
SAW WOULD HAVE BEEN ON STEROIDS.
MORE DEAD AMERICANS TRYING TO
GET OUT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A NIGHTMARE.
MILLEY DESERVES IMMENSE CREDIT
FOR PREVENTING THAT FROM HAVING
HAPPENED.
>> MILLEY DESERVES CREDIT.
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHY WHAT HE
DID IS OKAY AND NOT, MAYBE HE
HAD THE RIGHT FEELINGS, BUT IS
IT THE RIGHT WAY TO GO ABOUT IT?
OR ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO RESIGN
AND GO PUBLIC?
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S A TOUGH
SITUATION TO BE IN, CHRIS.
LOOK, I WITNESSED A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN IT.
I WAS IN THAT SPOT MYSELF.
I THINK WHAT'S REVEALING ABOUT
THIS EPISODE IS THAT THE
GUARDRAILS ARE SO THIN THAT
PEOPLE LIKE GENERAL MILLEY, I'M
SURE, IN HIS CASE, WERE WORRIED
IF HE LEFT AND SPOKE OUT, MAYBE
A MORE COMPLIANT PERSON WOULD BE
PUT IN HIS PLACE WHO WOULD
EXECUTE A NUCLEAR STRIKE FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO STAY IN OFFICE.
THAT'S THE DILEMMA A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE CLOSE TO THE PRESIDENT
FACED.
THE ANSWER BECOMES, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT NO LONGER WILL LISTEN
TO YOUR ADVICE AND WILL GO
AROUND YOU, THAT'S WHEN IT'S
TIME TO GO AND BLOW THE WHISTLE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DID DO THAT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THERE WERE FOLKS LIKE GENERAL
MILLEY AND OTHERS WHO STAYED TO
THE END TO KEEP THEIR HANDS ON
THE STEERING WHEEL AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE BEFORE THIS THING FELL
APART.
THE FACT THAT HE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT POTENTIALLY
STARTING A WAR AT THE END OF HIS
TERM ALARMS ME.
CHRIS, I'M GOING TO ADD ONE MORE
ANECDOTE.
DONALD TRUMP TALKED MULTIPLE
TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO US ABOUT HIS
POWERS OF DECLARING AN
INSURRECTION.
HE KNEW IF HE DECLARED AN
INSURRECTION, HE COULD DEPLOY
THE MILITARY TO THE STREETS AND
DO EXTRAORDINARY THINGS.
ON JANUARY 6, IT WAS MY
SUPPOSITION AS THE CAPITOL WAS
BEING STORMED THAT THE PRESIDENT
DID WANT TO INVOKE THE
INSURRECTION ACT TO PUT THE
MILITARY ON THE STREETS, TO
PREVENT A TRANSFER OF POWER,
BECAUSE HE TALKED TO US ABOUT IT
SO MANY TIMES.
THAT'S THE TYPE OF THING THAT
SHOWS PREMEDITATION IN MY
OPINION.
>> TWO QUICK THINGS.
ONE, WHEN DID HE TALK ABOUT
WANTING TO INVOKE THE
INSURRECTION ACT EARLY ON?
IN TERMS OF WHAT CONTEXT?
>> IT WAS AROUND THE BORDER.
I WANT TO SEE THE UNITED STATES
BORDER.
NO IMMIGRANTS COME IN.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD I HAVE MAGICAL
POWERS UNDER INSURRECTION ACT TO
DO THAT.
>> HE SAID MAGICAL POWERS?
>> HE DID.
VERBATIM, THOSE WERE HIS WORDS.
IT SOUNDS TRUMP-LIKE BECAUSE IT
WAS TRUMP'S WORDS.
HE SAID HE HAD MAGICAL POWERS.
HE SAID, I CAN USE THAT TO SHUT
DOWN THE BORDER.
WE WENT BACK TO OUR LAWYERS AND
CAME TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SAID, THERE'S NO INSURRECTION AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU CANNOT INVOKE THAT POWER.
THE PRESIDENT HAD THE IDEA OF
INSURRECTION IN HIS MIND.
THAT DAY, I'M SURE HE HAD THE
THOUGHT THAT HE COULD USE THOSE
POWERS IF HE WANTED TO TO DEPLOY
THE MILITARY INTO THE STREETS.
>> ONE OTHER THING.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A HOT
BUTTON.
MILLEY HAVING THE CONCERNS,
FINE.
MILLEY WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE CONCERNS, FINE.
MILLEY CALLING HIS CHINESE
COUNTERPART, MEETING WITH TOP
BRASS, TELLING THE CHINESE
COUNTERPART, DON'T WORRY,
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE FINE,
I WILL LET YOU KNOW IF WE WILL
ATTACK YOU, AND TELLING THE TOP
MILITARY BRASS, YOU COME TO ME
NO MATTER WHO TELLS YOU WHAT, DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT IS GOING
TOO FAR?
>> LOOK, ON THE CALL WITH THE
CHINESE, I THINK WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION.
IF MILLEY ACTUALLY DID SAY TO A
FOREIGN ADVERSARY, I WILL WARN
YOU BEFORE WE HIT YOU, AND IF WE
HAD A CREDIBLE REASON TO HIT AN
ADVERSARY, THAT'S DANGEROUS
TALK.
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE DETAILS.
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE MILLEY WAS
TRYING TO REACH OUT TO FOREIGN
COUNTERPARTS TO SAY, LET'S KEEP
THE TEMPERATURE LOW, YOU MAY
HEAR INSANE RHETORIC OUT OF
WASHINGTON, BUT LET'S TRY TO
KEEP IT FROM GOING TO WAR.
LIKE MANY STATESMEN HAVE
THROUGHOUT HISTORY TO TRY TO
KEEP TEMPERATURES LOW.
I HOPE THAT'S THE CA